good morning millennials welcome back to
the toast happy the Thursday hope
everyone's having a blessed day I am
because I'm joined by
yeah I made it I'm the world's greatest
I know it's R Kelly don't come for me
it's such a good song um
I know it's like so sad nothing like a
little R Kelly to start off the day so
true hey Jax how you darn darn good
thank you very much how about you
um do I look like puffy no
well I should because I was up all night
sobbing sobbing I did not go to bed till
2 30 in the morning sobbing from this
book in five years
I never tried like that I never cried
like that in my [ __ ] life what oh my
God I thought you were gonna say that
you were up sobbing from The Sound of
Music because I was oh you are because I
was I made it all the way to
intermission like remember when there
was an intermission in a movie was the
perfect time to turn it off I'm gonna
finish it tonight it was so good I was
getting like a little emotional it was
so beautiful but wow I can't believe
you're crying over in five years
saw I never I have cried two or three
two or three times at books and when I
say cry I mean like you know tears well
up yeah yeah maybe a tear
Jackie you would have thought someone
died
sobbing what about it spoiler alert but
this was a book that we read for the
redheads in 2020 so if you've been
keeping up like this is old news
spoiler alert okay in five years Rebecca
Searle about to be spoiled
her best friend dies of cancer and they
like literally take you through the
whole thing and then like they're oh my
God they're gonna cry talking about it
like she they're like ignoring that
she's gonna die like they they're like
they haven't even like thought about it
and then like the girl is like we need
to talk about it like I'm dying and it
was just oh my God
sobbed like I've never sobbed in my
whole life
so do you like the book love
wow because when we read it for the
redheads like we weren't that impressed
mind you it was when we were doing two
books a month during Coven Dark times
and we read it right after Before We
Were Strangers which we all loved but
then two weeks later later we read this
and like we're not a bunch of girls who
like read a lot of Romance Books in a
row so we were kind of fatigued and it
didn't get the shine that you're saying
it deserves
oh my God I'm obsessed I'm so glad that
you liked my recommendation loved loves
love thank you so much so if I'm looking
like puffy or my voice sounds like a
little horse it's because I was up all
night crying again did you finish the
book no no I it was so late Ben was
snoring and like I really needed to go
to bed I thought you were gonna find it
a little stupid
okay so I was about to find it stupid
but I I what I really like about the
book is it's all um about this dream
that that the girl has and I'm a person
who like I'm very in touch with my
subconscious I have crazy dreams I have
dreams that I've remembered since I was
a kid I have recurring dreams so I
actually liked that this book was like
referencing a dream because there are
dreams that I have there's like two or
three that I've had in my life that like
I I'm always thinking about got it okay
so it spoke to you I I'm I'm really
enjoying it um so I just wanted to say
like if I look you know not like my
usual supermodel self that's why it's
because you wear emoting I was also so
busy yesterday like podcast podcast
meeting midi meeting ended the show I
mean ended the day with our first ever
live podcast we did a live YouTube video
and audio podcast on our patreon
yesterday it was so fun it was a YouTube
live which we used to do every single
day for our show some of you guys are
new here but this show started as like a
Facebook live Instagram live and YouTube
live show let me eventually stop doing
Facebook and Instagram but for like many
years we would do this show Live on
YouTube and then record and then you
know upload it as a podcast but we had
the live chat and that was like a like a
really great part of the live element of
our old show and to kind of go back to
our roots with like there was like 4 000
people there they were chat and chat and
chatting like I was looking for it live
in for it it was so much fun I think
everyone had a really good time it was a
great way to spend the night we broke
down like a lot of the pop culture
stories from this week things that like
we didn't get a chance to talk about we
really dove into the sound of music
which inspired me to watch the movie and
it's so good and the more I thought
about it the more I was like this is my
perfect movie like it's a historical
period piece musical about the campers
speaking of musicals we also Dove deep
into the Glee documentary which has been
like a developing story online but it's
not really like interesting enough to
talk about on the toast but actually if
you look like deep enough it actually is
really interesting so we were able we
read like a review you
um that kind of you know read the
documentary to filth and we got to dive
deep into like the Glee curse it was a
really good episode like we did lots of
Pop Culture lots of Jackson Claude and I
had so much fun like I can't wait to do
it again yeah me too we'll definitely do
it again at next month so if you want to
watch the show after it happened you can
head over to patreon.com it's there
waiting to be watched and enjoyed by all
hunt over his hands hundred percent
um so today I have uh an exciting day
because after we wrap the toast I'm
going to record a podcast
with my twin
yes you are yes you are I'm so excited
are you able to say
yeah I'm doing Victoria Fuller she
already posted about it so I'm doing
Victoria Fuller's podcast like not my
twin it's gonna be like so much twin
energy in one Studio I just hope it's
not on video because it's gonna be
really confusing like who's talking I do
believe it is on video
damn well hopefully her voice is very
different than yours which I believe it
is I think it's lower and slower yeah no
but I'm excited to see her in person
like
to take looking at a mirror because I
always say like one of the most annoying
things about The Human Experience is
never being able to see your body like I
can look down on my legs but I can never
be you looking at me I will never see
what other people see it's like so
frustrating like and a mirror is really
not accurate so I think being in the
same room as Victoria Fuller will be the
closest I will ever get to seeing myself
Pig
okay a mirror is accurate except there's
always a part of me that's like what if
the mirrors are all lying and none of us
look like what we think nobody also when
you stand in front of a mirror you're
typically posing like even if you're
just standing in a way that's flattering
you never see yourself like 360. it's
two-dimensional yeah
it's not accurate
it's not accurate by the way when was
the mirror invented like did people used
to just like exist having no clue what
they looked like they would look at
their reflection in like a lake that's a
thesis in a lake like a lake
in a spoon
and then eventually the mirror came to
be but I think for a while there was
like reflective
surfaces
that weren't as clear as our mirrors now
they were no and foggy don't you shudder
to think what people will be seeing
their reflection in in a hundred years
[ __ ] scary they're gonna be like
looking at an x-ray machine I'm actually
I'm glad to be alive in the age of the
mirror like I didn't want to be looking
at my reflection in a lake because you
got to bend down to look at the lake and
then you got a double chin so I would
just be extremely insecure in the
Renaissance but maybe no maybe you're
secure because like you see this vision
of yourself that's like a little blurry
you know it's just a silhouette so I'm
looking good I don't see these details I
don't see that pimple that's true it's
like a little too much yeah we're
sitting a little too much now okay tell
me if this is like the worst call ever
do you feel like pimples are like a new
age thing I just refuse to believe
people like in the industrial times like
had pimples well people in the
industrial times definitely had pimples
because that smog was clogging up there
yeah for sure but I do think all of this
skincare it's a little chicken and egg
yeah and you see like I mean Ben loves
loves to say because he has Perfect Skin
because he doesn't put anything on his
face but I think he's also someone who's
just blessed with good skin I think that
definitely in the Renaissance there were
pimply teenagers but I also think that a
lot of current environmental factors and
also products that we have and consume
and like how everything has just a
bajillion chemicals like it's not
helping
I guess because like the only way I
Envision like the Renaissance is like
from TV like in the Gilded Age nobody
had pimples but it's because they're
actors yes yeah Okay and like if someone
in the Renaissance had their portrait
done like the artist isn't including the
pimple like a lot of those portraits are
extremely flattering photoshopped
Photoshop yeah face tune no that's so
true
so who knows what they were looking like
scary
yeah but maybe they think we look scary
with like our Botox and our big lips big
lips and like all of our makeup like a
couple of clowns I'm gonna be honest
with you guys you look like [ __ ]
clowns you know because people like in
the um
what I don't know what era it was called
but in like France you know Marie
Antoinette when they were wearing like
literal clown makeup like they thought
they were gorgeous and they're like big
wigs I'm having them yeah and they were
the big wigs confidence is a Timeless
asset yeah but
beauty is it's relative and it isn't
like I think it's also Timeless you know
I think there's a there's a certain
person who's beautiful in any era me
um so it's the hers day which means
we're so close we are so close you guys
hold on hold on for one more day
um tomorrow's Friday and we have a great
show today so by the time you're done
listening to this
it might even be time for like a late
afternoon snack and then you know sneak
it out of work early so we're gonna get
you through we're gonna sail into this
Friday yeah we really are though this
week has been
not nefarious it was a four day work
week and for that we are grateful yeah
so we need to acknowledge the good weeks
just like we acknowledge the bad weeks
so true Jax because some weeks never end
but today I woke up I was like it's the
hers day wow there are some weeks like I
swear to God that I'm still living in
like they're so long yeah
but not this week and we should
acknowledge you're correct it's a cute
little shorty award
sure please I'm triggered I'm sorry but
you need to like you need to confront
your triggers you can't be one of those
people that's like I can't say shorty
go shorty
it's your birthday gonna party like it's
your birthday I didn't really even tell
anyone because I genuinely forgot but
like last week was my half birthday I
thought you're celebrating your birthday
now on your half birthday I know I
forgot well maybe you celebrated it in
LA I think that's a good way to
celebrate yeah it was just like
frustrating because I wanted to have my
28th birthday
last week and I totally forgot space
because I'm so busy yeah so we'll we'll
party in July
I guess
you need to stop hating everything
everything that you can't change
um
no
because
I like it
[Laughter]
by the way no I like I am all for hating
things that you can change because it's
motivation to change it yeah but just
because you can't change something
doesn't mean you have to accept it like
no I'm still gonna hate that [ __ ] I
think you should I agree with you I
agree on the whole but I think you
should accept your birthday and find a
way to
if I enjoying it because it's every year
that this is like a struggle and really
now that you're grown like you need to
drop the childhood Camp trauma of not
like getting the birthday that you
wanted because now that as an adult like
having a summer birthday is popping like
all your teacher friends can come to
your birthday party I don't actually
have any like friends who I would invite
to a birthday party who are teachers I
don't think
maybe that's exciting to look inward
maybe that's a sign to make some
so okay yes I have summer birthday
Trauma from being a child like you know
everyone got parties at school and they
could have you know parties on the
weekend with all of their classmates and
I was in the summer and it was like I
wasn't with my family and like it was
just like well your sisters were there
we were there
at Sea Point yeah yeah no sorry I don't
know why I said that I didn't mean
family I meant like my home friends am I
gonna get a party at the house whatever
and I thought as an adult I'm like great
well now we're all adults and we have to
work so there is no real summer
it's arguably worse especially because I
loved Camp so all right I had to
celebrate my birthday at Camp sue me you
know
but now as an adult
people who work during the summer well
everyone works but during the summer
everyone's working so hard during the
week everybody makes the most of their
summer weekends they take road trips
they take regular trips they go see
family like nobody is really free on the
weekends of the summer
but that's because you say I'm not gonna
do anything with my birthday I'm not
gonna do anything for my birthday and
then the Thursday before your birthday
you're like why isn't everyone in the
city for my birthday weekend or like why
aren't people going to be in the
Hamptons like if you said now to your
friends who you want there we're doing a
weekend in the Hamp like I'm getting a
table at Surf Lodge my birthday weekend
like go be in the Hamptons they would
spend that weekend in the Hamptons
yeah you know what maybe I'll start
planning it now that's the lesson I will
say I do that every year I'm like I'm
not doing anything and then the day
before I like send out a paperless post
and I did the same thing and then your
shots when people are out of town but I
did the same thing last year and I will
say last year's really came together
flawlessly like it was my first good
birthday in a while I did and you know
what if anyone has a birthday summer or
not feel free to take this idea I did a
mystery bus ride so I basically told
everyone like get your ass to my house
nine o'clock Saturday night and there
was a bus outside I got like a big party
bus like we were going to prom like I
invited everyone I would say maybe 20 30
people came and it was a really good
crew it was a good night I didn't tell
anyone where we were going and I was
dropping hints along the way and I took
everyone to Chelsea Piers where we
bowled we did laser tag we went to the
arcade and then we ended the night with
a table at a club like it was actually a
really good birthday it was I had a
blast and everyone else did and they
were into the mysteriousness of it I
think a lot of people thought we were
going to Atlantic City
right which honestly is something I
would do but I would tell people like
pack a bag like you're gonna eat fresh
undies you're like I didn't buy clothes
for all you you know girl like the six
podcast is not like that successful I'm
not like out here getting rooms for you
guys it's not like a tart or a revolve
influencer trip where you get to your
room and you have all the clothes that
you need literally but now you have
enough Advanced window that like if you
wanted to plan that you could and I'm
sure you could get like work with a
hotel get rooms rooms are pretty easy to
come by but yeah when I stock the rooms
with clothes you're gonna have to start
reaching out to some Brands show me your
Momo
for the women
okay wait I don't know if you're aware
of like what's going down on Tick Tock
right now but there's like a tart trip
no so tarte has been like popping off
especially on Tick Tock
me too I love tart here it is me too
salt life but in different forms this is
the song by the way you should get this
this is Salt Life bomb it has like
ChapStick in it so I went to Sephora the
other day and I picked out a few nice
lipsticks and then the line was too long
so I just wrote down all the numbers and
left
um and I went to tarte and I didn't see
this shaped lipstick I saw this new one
and I was like there's no way that
there's salt life I just always assume
it's discontinued so I gave up but this
is shade salt life I didn't even check
out so I need to place that order I
found like a score just Pat McGrath
lipstick that I wanted to get okay so
tarte has been doing these like really
major influencer trips like honestly on
on the same level as revolve like with
amazing influencers to these amazing
places and they have truly outdone
themselves so they're in Dubai right now
they took like maybe 15 of the biggest
and baddest tick-tockers to Dubai um
they flew them all first class Emirates
everyone is sharing so much content and
they're staying at the Ritz Carlton and
like everyone got their own Villa and
you walk into the villa and there is
clothes makeup like it's insane it's
honestly probably crazier than I've seen
any revolve anything like it's insane
and it's like all the girls that people
really love like Monet McMichaels and
Alex Earl like people who you've been
following for a long time is there yeah
and she brought her mom like it's like
it's because it's like such a big deal
and everyone is like so excited because
you you know you feel excited for these
girls like you really were a part of
their journey and of course everything
has to turn negative literally before
you even said that I'm like when you
feel a part of someone's Journey it's
about to turn right so now like the
narrative has turned I've seen like
people being like this is so wasteful
like we're in a recession with inflation
this just feels so out of touch and it's
like what I feel like inflation is such
a big problem right now and nobody's
really talking about it but when it
comes to the tarte influencer trip all
of a sudden it's a big yeah now let's
let's complain about inflation yeah HR
at people who have nothing to do with it
right no and it's like you know
inflation is we're living in dark
Economic Times we are headed to slash
already in a recession and it's gonna be
a long time like two things can be true
you know
but what the [ __ ] does that have to do
with tarte and tarte is like a female
owned business I the the owner she's
really like tart has really been popping
off I feel like they had a a big moment
a few years ago and then with all these
like new brands they kind of took like a
back step and now they're really popping
off again and so the owner's content has
been like coming up on my feed she's
like a mom she started this business all
by herself like it's an inspiring story
like what the [ __ ] chill yeah I also
imagine that so much of it is
sponsored and paid for like tart didn't
pay I don't think for every single thing
like if there's a room full of stuff and
all these influencers are going to be
posting about it like it's probably free
for like tarkco that's how revolve works
like yeah and actually those brands that
revolve like brings on their trip the
brands pay revolve like revolve actually
to the at this point makes money from
that stuff so it's not like tarte is out
here spending so much money no and I
wouldn't be surprised if like did you
buy Board of Tourism is also working
with you yeah because it's such great
you know uh exposure marketing for Dubai
it's like this great destination to
travel the Ritz Carlton I'm sure they'll
be doing you know like cool sand dunes
like activities so I would not be
surprised if they got a lot of it for
free no like you could go to a brand and
be like the 15 biggest Beauty tick
tockers are going to be posting what we
are putting in this gift bag do you want
to be a part of it yeah you don't have
to pay for that yeah no I agree so I
just like people people will make like
drama out of anything it was so
disheartening because it's like it's
exciting I love I'm obsessed with Monet
McMichael like she's really just like a
regular girl and she just like really
works hard on her content and she has
blown up over the last year and it's
like it's exciting like to watch
people's hard work pay off and it's like
someone I actually saw someone say like
I was reading comments I just wanted to
see how like unwell
they were like it's so disgusting that
these girls are getting products that
are sold out online
what
no that's really disgusting people are
not okay you know it's disgusting no
it's like on the one hand like let's
focus on these big issues inflation like
yes on the other hand and the products
are sold out online no and people have
really gotten really carried away with
language that's disgusting no you know
it's disgusting human trafficking okay
calm down
she said it she said it talk update of
the day
wow I want to see these trips yeah by
the way it looks sick is Michaela there
I don't know I don't think so actually
because she's to me as an outsider like
the biggest Beauty tick tocker
is she is I don't know if she's the most
influential anymore but she's the
biggest in terms of numbers I think she
has 14 or 15 million followers yeah
right I would say right now Alex Earl is
the most everything she posts yes she's
having no her big moment right that
those moments don't last forever so
hopefully she's like building a good
business around yes yeah exactly
that's what the kids are up to very
exciting I hope everyone's having a
blast on their trip me too
so I guess without further Ado shall we
Dive Right In to the fast five stories
that you need to know
today's episode is brought to you by new
sponsor we haven't spoken about yet but
I've been using for a while thanks to
the skinny confidential is the canopy
humidifier so for a long time I've been
using a humidifier Ben was very into
humidifiers and I'm like sir this is not
the vibe and he was like trust me he
really believes in the power of
humidifiers and I was not a Believer I
was a skeptic but for my skin my sleep
and just like my overall Wellness a
humidifier
is game changing but traditional models
are notorious for being fugly they can
get really moldy and be really hard to
maintain I've actually thrown out like
three or four drugstore humidifiers they
do not last well but that's where the
canopy humidifier comes in so it's
recommended by Leading dermatologists it
is a completely reimagined humidifier
that elevates your home for the ultimate
in skin care and wellness benefits
canopy's unique features and design make
it the easiest cleanest humidifier out
there it's truly
um the best kept secret for healthy skin
I've definitely noticed like especially
in the winter I can wake up with like
crack dry skin I've noticed a huge
difference but also where I notice the
biggest difference is I feel like during
the winter months for the last couple of
years like I wake up with like a sore
throat almost like it feels it's so dry
and it takes me like a few minutes to
drink water brush my teeth before like I
feel like my throat isn't constricted
but having a humidifier on my nightstand
has made such a difference and Ben wants
to kill me because he's been telling me
four years about humidifiers and I just
didn't believe I'm like yeah sure
whatever like whatever bed says like
Banning his problems yeah I'm like you
mean your Eastern medicine I'm like stop
I was so wrong and it's important to
acknowledge when you're wrong the canopy
humidifier has clean no mist moisture
that effortlessly hydrates your skin to
combat dryness dullness and fine lines
and wrinkles it's a hassle-free
technology inhibits mold growth and the
parts that go right into the dishwasher
it is that easy to clean so go to
getcanopy.com to save 25 on your canopy
humidifier purchase today with canopy's
Filter subscription you could also use
code toast at checkout to save an
additional 10 off your canopy purchase
your skin will thank you when you go to
getcanopy dot Co today's episode is also
brought to you
by ZipRecruiter unfortunately you also
have a new hiring challenge for 2023
like finding qualified candidates for
adjusting or adjusting to candidates
work preferences thankfully there's a
place you can go to to help you conquer
those challenges and achieve your goals
when it comes to hiring and that is zip
recruiter and right now you can try it
for free at ziprecruiter.com toast so
why ZipRecruiter they uses they use
their powerful technology
to match you and find the right
candidates for your job you can see a
candidate who'd be perfect for your job
and then ZipRecruiter makes it easy to
send them a personal invite so they're
more likely to apply you have to wait
for people to apply they're being
proactive for you they're getting out
there
ZipRecruiter offer also offers more
attention grabbing labels that speak to
the job flexibility like whether you're
offering a remote position if there's
training provided and more so really is
getting your job listing into the right
candidates and they're putting forth the
information that you need to know like
is this where remote do I need to come
into the office all the different things
let's ZipRecruiter help you find the
best people for all of your roles four
out of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself go
to ziprecruiter.com toast and try it for
free again that's ziprecruiter.com
t-o-a-s-t to try ZipRecruiter for free
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire if
you're looking for some beautiful
setting and smart candidates the
recruiter is a great place to start yes
it is
thank you Claudia you are welcome are
all the codes and all the links that'll
save
our first story Kim Kardashian buys
famous Princess Diana amethyst cross
pendant for 197 453 at auction okay I
know we're living in dark Economic Times
but I feel like there's like not that
much money like for a like a like a
piece of jewelry that's probably made
you know out of the best of the best and
that has such historical and cultural
significance
yes and no like it's
5.25 carats and allegedly like this went
for double what they thought it was
gonna go for at the Sunrise auction so
it's like I think the
history of something definitely makes it
worth a bit more but if it's not like
you know made out of
canary diamonds then it's only worth so
much but I mean it's still it's amethyst
so it's what it's amethyst okay so
that's not like forget me I'm I'm not
you know caught kept up on my gems but
I'm not a general amethyst is not a
diamond
it's diamond encrusted amethyst oh so it
has like a border of diamonds but the
the main thing the purple thing is not
diamonds it's yeah yeah because jewelry
like has sold for like there's millions
of dollars right jewelry so I agree with
what you're saying it's not like the
craziest priced jewelry thing we've ever
heard but I mean that's a lot for a
[ __ ] necklace for sure anyways on
Wednesday Kim purchased the diamond
encrusted amethyst atala cross pendant
famously worn by Princess Diana at
Sotheby's annual Royal and Noble auction
having fomo I'm quaking
I would love to know what else was sold
and if this like if I were Kim maybe
Granny's license maybe Granny's
pantyhose
let me just Google Sotheby's Royal and
Noble and also it's an annual auction
oh also I wonder who was selling it like
not who who owns it who owned it
honestly
that's true because I feel like if
William or Harry had it they wouldn't
sell it okay there's a lot of China
plates cups glassware
Furniture Old Ass Furniture was it a
necklace owned by Diana or worn by Diana
great question it was definitely worn by
Diana but probably no longer owned by
the time they sell sell it yeah so the
uh London head of jewelry for sotheby
said this is a bold piece of jewelry by
its size color and style which cannot
fail to make a vibrant statement whether
it be Faith or fashion or indeed both we
are delighted that this piece has found
a new lease of life within the hands of
another globally famous name so I
personally think like this is a great
buy for Kim one she is she loves like to
wear a big cross this is an iconic one
Christian girly it's you know a piece of
History she obviously has the means to
buy such things and I think that it's in
the right hands for its next life yeah
but I could just see because you know
everyone hated when she wore the Marilyn
dress people just being like this is
tacky like history needs to be preserved
it's not in the right hands you know yes
of course but I don't feel like it's a
situation like that like no chemicals if
she had bought that Marilyn dress right
I think it would have been a little
different like what can you say right
it's capitalism baby you know
possession is nine tenths the law right
so it would have been hers to rip rip
right it would have been her strip
Olivia
um no you're totally right
I think that this is great I always
forget like Kim is like religious you
know yeah not religious but spiritual
she's pretty religious the whole family
is right but you know what's so
interesting to me about like other
religions and specifically like here
Kim is Christian
and Diana and the family they're uh
Church of England right yeah that's
Catholic no it's not
what is it it's Protestant okay it's
just so interesting how like you could
be like different religions but you have
the same necklace you know what I mean
well it's all under one no I get it I
get it I'm sure they have other symbols
that vary by yeah that's true like
denomination Episcopalian Dove or
something yeah maybe there's a dove
actually a dove is pretty Universal I
think we love a dub too in Judaism dubs
are actually you're totally right the
Dove and the Olive Branch yeah yeah I
love olives thanks Selena I do love
olives thanks Selena
um anyways I think this is really funny
to me like sorry to cut you off but you
know I am alive
um
it's so funny to me like what
sticks with you you know I feel like
you're always squeezing me like yeah
you're always quoting like either things
that we say on the toast or things from
Instagram or things from my comedy
special it's never like the funniest
moment it's like this most random like
teacher is happy you know from from my
new special coming out soon yeah and
then from your old special it's just
infinitely quotable to me yeah no I just
think it's funny like what sticks with
you I know I don't know what it is it's
something about
the Trope like the I didn't even think
it was that funny when I did that Selena
Gomez for those who don't know what it's
from I did my food tasting series with
Selena Gomez I tried olives for the
first time with Selena and then I ended
the video being like this is disgusting
thanks Selena I love olives
but the way that you said it was funny
was it yeah go back and watch it I
actually watched it yesterday or like in
a vomit and being like thanks Selena I
love the olives
well honestly you're my biggest fan and
I can't tell you how much that means to
me oh that's so sweet um but other
question answered that this was owned by
um a long line of people who were not
Diana it was only ever worn by the
princess
um and they hadn't been seen in public
until now but it had a long-standing
history with the court Jewelers garage
which designed the pendant in the 1920s
it was later bought by the late Naima
tala CBE the former group's chief
executive of asprey and Gerard who often
loaned the one-of-a-kind gem to Princess
Diana in the 80s so if you had like you
know it was Diana's from the 80s oh
good one
um okay so if you were Kim or like you
were you and you had you know unlimited
disposable income to like purchase
fashion from like you know from history
or from you know pop culture like what
would you buy
I would have to look at my options
obviously I wouldn't buy a cross
but
I would definitely look at the Royal
what's up for sale like in the Royal
adjacent because they're not selling the
crown jewels but like did the Queen
Victoria ever get a loner necklace yeah
no I wonder if like Elizabeth Taylor
ever did like a big sale of her jewelry
and auctioned off any like gorgeous you
know Jewish star necklace you know she's
definitely sold some stuff because I
think Kim owns some Elizabeth Taylor
stuff oh yeah but even in this Sotheby's
thing like there's some really beautiful
art I could go for some art yeah uh even
the China is nice but like it's hard to
get excited about China when you're only
30. no and like you literally can't cook
what me not you no I like I have wedding
China and I've still never used it okay
but what's the difference between China
and a plate
is what it's made out of
so China's like made out of like it's it
could be like bone china which is like
material or like porcelain and it's very
fine so my Kate Spade home plates not
China oh so I don't have any China
I literally have never like I cannot
remember the last time I set my table
actually no you won't use it now like
even now when I have Thanksgiving I use
my really nice plates there by Lennox
that would be like your Kate Spade
adjacent ones but like in your life you
will want chime you will use China I
guess like you don't have to but like
eventually like there's a time and a
place yeah I guess and it's one of those
things that even though you would think
like old smelly food plates they
wouldn't get passed down like they're
they get passed down right it's not a
wasteful thing like they go no it's like
an heirloom
it's like an heirloom exactly
cool there's a lot of swords in the
Sotheby's auction so far the cross was
the only thing I saw so Kim did good
yeah she must have had a rise on it for
a while yeah I wonder what else she has
her eyes on
I guess we'll have to find out that
she's like waiting to go up for auction
yeah
a lot of
silk coats so today I actually decided
to drink a coffee
um because I was up all night crying
um and I just felt like I was kind of
tired and now I remember why I like
stopped drinking coffee like I have to
poop like that's a real problem it is a
real problem how do you do it you drink
Claudia too there's an Edwardian scale
what the [ __ ] is that a scale like Fred
the doctor
oh I'm good next to it is an old Ash
chair that went for 120 pounds I should
have like bought a little trinket I'm
I'm gonna skip skip I can't talk I'm
gonna stick with my ww scale that I
bought off of Amazon love that for you
there's a group of linen and Lace
vestimates that were 100 pounds okay so
there's like you know there's something
for everyone some budget items
um
yeah maybe next year I'm sorry you have
to poop do you want to go do that no no
no I was just wondering like how you
podcast having two coffees in you and
you don't have to like literate every
time we cut we run to the bathroom drain
your bowels or you go before okay
I'm fine
clench I am
are you ready for our next story which
is actually a little more Kim adjacent
news considering we haven't talked about
her in five months and now it's okay to
have not spoken about her forever like
she's been laying low one and two any
story that's been about her it's just
been like kind of annoying
um but today there's two
worth our discussion okay
cardi B says Kim Kardashian gave me
plastic surgery advice so cardi B has
outed Kim's alleged best kept secret
that she's had plastic surgery right Kim
has repeatedly denied cosmetic
modification claims but cardi claimed
that the big bootied Starlet gave her a
list of cosmetic surgeons cardi B was on
the first episode of the Jason Lee
podcast and she got honest about her
nose job and butt lift and she said that
Kim gave her a list of the most trusted
doctors in town okay that headline's
misleading a little bit but so Jason
said okay so how do you decide who
you're going to go to and Trust to touch
your face and body because I remember
the time we were at Chris's house and
Kim gave you a list of people you could
call and get help you didn't call none
of those people you just did it at home
cardi B said no I cup I called a couple
of the people that she gave me
okay so the headline makes it seem like
Kim gave her a list of procedures and oh
yeah no he or she should do no honestly
to me obviously Kim has had work done if
she's going to deny it that's her
prerogative honestly I'm not gonna like
you know get up in arms about it
um but I don't think this is necessarily
an admission an admission of plastic
surgery like Kim obviously is the most
glamorous woman in Hollywood she's very
well connected I would take a doctor
recommendation from her as well
yes also even on her Instagram like
she'll post Dr Orion Jason Diamond Jason
Diamond even though what she shows is
like her getting like a face they also
do surgery so I feel like
it's not a complete admission also it's
really the other guy who's who like
called her out and was like when we were
at Chris's house Kim gave you a list of
doctors so cardi B I don't know if she
would have said that if he didn't say it
yeah
it's getting late at Cardi's feet like
I'm sure Kim's gonna read this headline
and be like [ __ ] no and it makes cardi
B look bad like she was being a gossip
but this guy was being like these guys
the straw that stirs the dress yeah no
and he's like trying to draw it out of
her and he said Kim gave you a list of
doctor it's the first episode of his
podcast like he obviously wanted to make
waves because he was being like a drama
queen here yeah and he did because we're
talking about it 100 mission
accomplished so I hope his podcast does
well we were number four in comedy
yesterday
um
and like so you can't tell us nothing no
you really can unfortunately you could
try you could but you couldn't
right
uh yeah so anyways
I don't think anybody on Earth really
thinks that Kim hasn't had
plastic surgery the thing is she's very
choosy about what she says she hasn't
had like it actually did this Allure
story where she said I haven't I uh I've
never had eyelash extensions I've never
done anything I've never filled my
cheeks I've never filled my lips I
believe her that she hasn't done those
things yeah because if you look back on
pictures of her like she did always have
pretty big lips yeah
so and it doesn't actually look like she
has crazy fake lips Chloe looks like she
has a little injection in there and Kim
doesn't look like she has stuff put in
her cheeks I feel like Kim wouldn't want
filler in her cheeks I don't know what I
feel like my my gut instinct whenever we
have this conversation about the
Kardashians but just about like
celebrities in general like
you know what like really people do not
owe us
a laundry list of what they've had done
like it's people's bodies it's their own
[ __ ] business like and I think like
this expectation that everyone because
and I get it it's like I get the
opposing argument which is like you know
it's creating this toxic Beauty standard
to not share what you've had done
because then people will you know be
like well why don't I look like that I
get it but at the same time like
celebrities are human beings and every
human being no matter who you are or
what you do for a living is entitled to
privacy especially when it comes to like
their body and their physical appearance
so I agree I'm just out of this mind I
agree but I just don't think people
should lie but I don't think Kim has
lied I I like she's clearly like
answered bits and pieces of the question
but I don't think she's outright said
I've not done something that she has
done yes that's true so that's what I
think but I think she chose the line
pretty well and also like nobody really
asks her I feel like
they know better you know what I mean
that she has a million interviews nobody
asks like
what'd you do yeah
are you ready for our next question yeah
rapper Flo Rida has been awarded nearly
83 million dollars in a fight with an
energy drink maker I'm obsessed with
this story I was watching footage of him
in court they like had to play his music
like for like evidence
and he was like jam it out what's up
baby it was so baby he honestly I feel
like I know every single one of Flo
Rida's song I could not like pick a
point point to you point him to point
him out to you on the street like I have
no idea what he looks like he's such a p
job yeah he is and now he's getting his
big payday he was awarded 83 million
dollars uh on Wednesday after a South
Florida jury found that the makers of
Celsius energy drinks breached a
contract with the rapper and singer and
tried to hide money from him so it's
crazy that it's Celsius because
they're very huge impact I thought it
was going to be some like energy drink
that I never heard of but right when you
hear why and how he got the money it
makes sense he had sued Celsius claiming
that the company had violated the
conditions of an endorsement deal he
said quote basically I helped birth this
company and all we were looking for was
some trustworthy people who acted as if
they were family and then when it comes
down to the success of today they just
forgot about me lawyers for Celsius
argued in court and in previous filings
that the company reached its greatest
success after the Florida endorsement
deal ended and that other business
decisions led to increased sales and
stock value Celsius could appeal the
verdict but it wasn't immediately clear
if they would so basically
um they had terms in their original like
sponsorship deal that like when they had
certain benchmarks Flo Rida would get
stock right and they were trying to
argue that they hadn't hit those
benchmarks in order to like not give him
what he deserved but
Justice did its thing and said he
deserves 83 million dollars no that's so
[ __ ] shady of them but I love a Flo
Rida for like sticking up to it for
himself you know obviously Flo Rida is a
man of means and he has the means but
it's still really scary to go up against
like what is probably like a billion
dollar company yeah especially if
they're I think they were arguing over
one percent of ownership that he was
promised and wow turns into 83 million
dollars something like that I love this
for him I had no idea he was such a big
part of Celsius growth I don't really
drink Celsius and I didn't know it was
like that big of a company I feel like
it was something like only influencers
drink oh really no I feel like it's so
big and it's a great
idea and it tastes good let me tell you
I didn't know it was an audio an audio
I'm not okay I didn't know it was a
energy drink energy is kind of like when
I heard energy drink I was thinking
something like Red Bull monster oh no I
guess that would be this because Celsius
is just a carbonated sparkling beverage
that has so much [ __ ] caffeine but
it's not nasty like Red Bull like Red
Bull like taste like a fuels so good
Celsius tastes just like a sparkling
fruity drink
maybe I'll get into that yeah you should
drink a Celsius in the morning
totally yeah and I used to drink Celsius
more when like I remember I had some
Celsius when we were in Nashville
because I was like not drinking as much
as you guys so it's like a fun it looks
like a white claw but yeah alcohol and
just tons of caffeine like that's what I
want oh I kind of love that yeah
you know in my old age I'm like really
affected by caffeine like I used to be
able to have a Diet Coke at midnight and
like go to bed I had a Diet Coke at five
o'clock last night and that's why I was
up till three we'll just have caffeine
free
yeah I know low-key caffeine free is
hard to find like at grocery stores it's
always gone and sometimes they just
don't even carry it
I'm sorry especially Diet Pepsi caffeine
free that's like impossible to find I
don't even know what that looks like me
neither
because the diet coke ones are bronze
they're bronze they're kind of stunning
yeah they're like gold metal I love this
83 million dollar win for Flo Rida I am
jealous but also happy for him yeah
um
agreed on All Points no
um that's so great and I would love to
hear what you have to say next but if I
can just let you know that today's
episode is brought to you by Squarespace
would that be okay yeah that would be
really great because I think everybody
really needs to know about Squarespace
especially if they want to start their
own business or platform themselves
don't wait for someone to platform you
no do it yourself
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business so if you have a side
hustle a small business you're working
e-commerce and you need to build a
website and you have no idea where to
start go to Squarespace it is so easy
building a website can be so
intimidating I feel like from like blogs
like I've really been like making
websites like I started out like you
know posting pictures I have like used
so many of the platforms out there
Squarespace is so easy like to design
first of all you don't need to know
anything about like software engineering
their templates are really easy to use
to get you know the domain that you want
if you want you know gorgeousgirlies.com
they will help you secure the domain
that you want it's all in one place
and then also
um you can have multiple contributors if
you people working for you you can give
contributors selective access to your
site's website manager depending on
their permissions so if you have a team
it's really easy to collaborate they
also help you you know see your traffic
at a glance see how your visits unique
visitors page views Trend over time you
can gain insight into the truck the top
traffic sources top products what type
of devices people are using what
browsers they're coming from and you own
all the content that you put on the
squares Place Squarespace platform
because Squarespace offers a one-click
data portability so head to
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use our
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
again that's squarespace.com toast
today's episode is also brought to you
by nutrifall millions of Americans
experience thinning hair it's more than
common it's completely normal but it's
not openly talked about especially for
women so going through it if you've been
through it you know it can feel really
lonely frustrating like maybe even a
little embarrassing but it's time to
change the conversation and join the
thousands of women who are standing up
for their strands with neutralfall it is
the number one dermatologist recommended
hair growth supplement it's clinically
shown to improve your hair growth in
thickness and the visible scalp coverage
I feel like there are a lot of products
out there that claim to help with hair
growth but neutrophil is such a
reputable brand I feel like their
products are really really well made
they use the best ingredients and if
you're really looking to actually make a
change check out
their hair growth supplement
it helps by targeting the five root
causes of fitting which is stress
hormones the environment nutrition and
metabolism and it does that through
whole body Health they have three unique
formulas to support women throughout all
stages of life so a lot of women you
know experience hair thinning when
they're postpartum when they're in
menopause and they will Target
those times of your life based on the
supplement so each formula is physician
formulated they use natural drug-free
medical grade ingredients and it is
constantly it is consistently effective
dosage so that you can get the most
reliable results in a clinical study 86
of women reported improved hair growth
after six months you can grow thicker
healthier hair and support our show by
going to neutrophone.com enter the promo
code toast to save 15 off your first
month's subscription it's their best
offer anywhere and it is only available
to us customers for a limited time they
also offer free shipping on every order
when you go uh to nutrifall
n-u-t-r-a-f-o-l-.com use the promo code
toast for 15 off and free shipping on
your order nutrifall.com promo code
toast thank you McLaren you're welcome
our next story has just been bumped for
some breaking news
oh what Alec Baldwin and the rust female
armorer will be charged with involuntary
manslaughter over his fatal shooting of
cinematographer Helena Hutchins and they
face up to 18 months in jail
uh New Mexico New Mexico First Judicial
District Attorney Mary Carmack altuice
and Russ special prosecutor Andrea Reeb
announced the charges in a written
statement today both Baldwin and
guterres Reed face a maximum of 18
months in prison if convicted Dave
Hall's the assistant director has
pleaded guilty to the charge of
negligent use of a deadly weapon quote
the special prosecutor said if any one
of these people three people Alec
Baldwin Hannah Gutierrez read or David
Halls had done their job Helena Hutchins
would still be alive today it's that
simple Alec Baldwin has yet to respond
to the charges but his wife Hilaria was
seen of course the school run shortly
before the announcement was made all
right she's allowed she's a yeah yeah I
thought it was gonna be she went on
Instagram yeah
um I'm shocked I know
I mean it's so weird because at the end
of the day like a woman died a young
mother lost her life for no reason
and somebody should be held responsible
yeah
but also you know if everything went
down the way they say it went down
it was like genuinely an accident yeah
and I guess that's what negligence is
it's like of course you had no bad
intentions but at the end of the day
like there were consequences right and
like involuntary manslaughter just not
carry the same sentences it's about
intention no I know it's just like kind
of crazy it is but that's also what a
trial is for yeah so I feel like it's
crazy that it's that he's actually being
charged I feel like everyone had kind of
forgotten about it and it felt like
there was just
it was just being swept under the rug
but clearly you know the judicial forces
in New Mexico have been working on this
and are not just going to let it fall by
the wayside so
it's good that there will be a trial
Alec will have every opportunity to
defend himself I'm sure he'll have the
best lawyers and and make the best case
for himself and and also I think a lot
of the truth of what actually happened
will come out because
we have no idea really how that happened
like why on God's green diddly Dallas
there would be a live bullet on a movie
set no 100 and
for me like this you're right like
everyone kind of like moved on from this
very quickly and I feel like Alec
Baldwin went back very quickly just
being a celebrity posting on Instagram
and to me like that's the weirdest
and most disrespectful part of it like
he definitely took a break maybe like
two months
but you would think like accidentally
killing someone would destroy a person
yeah and Alec appears to like have
bounced back and it's so kind of
sociopathic in my mind yeah and I'm not
saying I want him to be you know forlorn
for the rest of his life and never be
the same but a normal human reaction is
like that [ __ ] changes you yeah you
don't know what true his interior life
is like but I would agree with you and
you would think he would like want to
you know Express on his social media and
like just for his image like
like he would want to express it he's
like pulled back a little but he hasn't
yeah but then you're making videos
begging people to follow Hilaria on
Instagram also I would just say Devil's
Advocate is that if he knows that this
is about to become a legal proceeding if
he spent all his time on Instagram
talking about how sorry he was like
that's and I'm not saying he should do
that that's just not
good in court you know no no I get it I
get it which is unfortunate because like
you know
it's just
it's so
it's so weird but there's like low-key
like a lot of celebrities who have like
killed people
involuntarily involuntarily uh I believe
Matthew Broderick
really yeah Google it he was like
driving on the wrong side of the highway
like when he was really young
Caitlyn Jenner that car accident
remember
oh wait here's an article 12 famous
people who have killed someone yeah it's
like Loki like weird
okay okay Matthew Broderick while
driving in Ireland
with his then gal pal Jennifer Gray oh
from um Dirty Dancing he veered into
oncoming traffic and crashed into a car
head-on the other driver died and he was
fined 175 dollars for careless driving
yeah
Brandy failed to break in time and hit
the car in front of her Brandy Glenville
or no
AJ's sister okay
the other driver was killed but Brandy
was never charged with a crime
yeah it's kind of interesting
yeah
all very sad
so I mean we'll just have to see it and
you're right we have no answer for what
the [ __ ] happened so a trial isn't the
worst thing just to get to the bottom of
it
yes I agree and you know when someone
dies in in such a way like they deserve
a trial like a hundred percent she
deserves first to play out and if
anybody is responsible to be held
responsible wow what crazy breaking news
thank you so much for sharing that
you're welcome are you ready for our
fifth and final story I am
give me a second because Carol Baskin
says her dead husband was found alive I
heard no one noticed
Carol Baskin declared that her missing
ex-husband Don Lewis was found alive in
Costa Rica but the discovery is just now
going viral over a year later during a
resurfaced November 2021 interview with
itb's this morning talk show Carol
alleged that her ex who was declared
legally dead in 2002 after disappearing
a few years before was actually alive
and well however not everyone is buying
it Carol Baskin told the post herself
that she was unaware of the alleged
Revelation until the sequel series was
broadcast in November 2021. quote I was
not aware of it until tk2 aired she said
the post via email as much confusion and
online debate ignited on social media
the animal rights activist alleged in
the resurfaced ITV footage that the
Department of Homeland Security has been
in touch with her former spouse
huh but she said she didn't know and
then there's an interview where she says
she does I guess she didn't know until
tk2 and then in the interview she said
that he's alive and then the interview
has now resurfaced one year later my God
we have beat this Tiger King thing so
dead like I don't care uh okay I don't
care because I never watched Tiger King
like I legit don't care but I just want
to say
based on this is my outside perspective
but like everybody called Carol Baskin a
murderer shoot they like protested her
Beyond Dancing with the Stars because
like there was a vibe that she murdered
her husband Carol Baskin killed her
killed her husband whacked him like the
whole country went on and on with this
narrative based on just some um
uh what's the word inferring inferences
from a documentary and this woman was
branded a murderer and her husband is
alive like we oh not me not me because I
had no nothing to do with this we owe
her an apology a big word a hundred
percent right and you know who actually
really owes her an apology is Netflix
yeah like they ran with that narrative
and then people loved it but like they
started it yeah and it's like if this
man was alive like go find him like you
guys have research teams like yeah it's
just sad and I also feel like if this
Narrative of her wasn't painted like
Tiger King was the biggest show in the
world like she would have had more of a
career but like no more of a way to hire
the alleged murderer no you're
completely right it's like all fun and
games and then you like to sit back and
look at this at a glance it's like we
all it was like a like a just a fact
like Carol Baskin murdered her husband
you know right right
and she didn't but and like that has
consequences yeah but we can just like
take it off it's so indicative of the
world we live in now like rumors start
people say crazy things and then like
years later we find out that they're not
true and there's no like
recourse recourse no I was gonna say
yeah recourse like there's no payback
like there's no apology that like I feel
like that [ __ ] happens all the time
literally Ariel chart us literally Manti
Teo
you see he welcomes a second baby with
his wife no I didn't yeah how sweet man
I miss our Manti era I miss our man
tyara too I forgot about that that was
that to me is like the perfect example
of like just completely well I I don't
really watch sports but like just the
world like comes up with this narrative
and like it's over for someone and run
with it like we don't give anyone ever
the benefit of the doubt right
right and it's like if you were to give
Carol Baskin the benefit of the towel
back then it's like you support a
murderer right but innocent until proven
guilty it's all very confusing I sneezed
on it it's true
so
that's the lesson the lesson from
today's episode because it's so
important to always take a lesson with
you I'll quote the Bible have they done
give people the benefit of the doubt
okay chill chill yeah and just like
pause okay just pause for a second take
a step back take a step back take
inventory
love that damn the episode took a turn
100
um but that's our show a nice little
short Thursday tomorrow is our last
episode of the week because it's Friday
Friday gotta get down on Friday
everybody's looking forward to the
weekend weekend Friday Friday getting
down on Friday
thank you guys looking forward to the
weekend party and party and yeah party
and partying yeah yeah fun fun fun
looking forward to the weekend the
weekend
thank you guys so much for listening to
the toast the Millennium Morning Show
where we deliver the past five stories
that you need to know every Monday
through Friday on YouTube so if you're
watching this on YouTube please feel
free to subscribe and give this video a
thumbs up we're also available as a
podcast anywhere podcast can be found so
at Spotify action Stitch or public radio
I heard we do castbox all the places
where we listen to podcast my nest of
the toast leave a five-star review about
how beautiful stunning and
Wicked lit talented we are hope you guys
have it in club Thursday we'll see you
tomorrow for Friday Friday gotta get
down on Friday bye love you bye